why this book what's the motivation and
well i
followed closely your lectures on
genesis and
when i was listening to them i was
really fascinated because again and
again i saw
themes that i had read earlier in the
church fathers people like augustine
chrysostom origin
and you were reading scripture according
to
what's called the moral reading of
scripture where you're looking at the
story of say cain and abel and your
primary question isn't was there
actually two brothers someone named kane
and someone named abel you're not so
much looking for the historical facts
you might say in terms of cain and abel
but rather you're looking at that story
in terms of what universal lessons the
story has for us today and that moral
reading of scripture is something that
is very very common in the christian
tradition of
uh biblical reading and so i thought
that was super interesting and then i
also thought it was interesting how
you were bringing to bear all kinds of
other resources when looking at these
stories so you would bring in
evolutionary
psychology you'd bring in russian novels
you'd bring in all these things that
would seem to be foreign to the biblical
text but in a way that too was something
that was very traditional in other words
if you look at people like augustine
he'll say that all truth is from god and
so bringing in
any truth from any field is perfectly
legitimate in his view in terms of
trying to understand scripture because
he thinks that god is the ultimate
author of two books the book of
revelation scripture but also the book
of creation so everything in creation
can help inform our understanding of
scripture and scripture can help inform
understanding of creation
[Music]
hello everyone i'm pleased to have with
me today dr christopher kaiser and dr
matthew petruck
they're both working at loyola marymount
university
and they recently co-authored a book
called
jordan peterson god in christianity the
search for a meaningful life which is
definitely
a title that i would never have imagined
existing
so
i
decided to
talk to them today to see what sort of
useful discussion we might have
about that book
but about christian issues more broadly
religious issues more broadly cultural
issues
um
dr kaizor is professor of philosophy and
a fellow of the word on fire institute
which we'll discuss a little later he
graduated from the honors program of
boston college and earned his phd four
years later
from the university of notre dame
he was a fulbright scholar who did
postdoctoral work as an alexander von
humboldt german chancellor fellow at the
university of cologne
he was appointed he was appointed a
corresponding member of the pontifical
academy for life of vatican city
and william e simon visiting fellow in
the james madison program at princeton
university the winner of a templeton
grant templeton funds
research into the intersection between
religion and science among other things
he's written more than a hundred
scholarly articles and book chapters and
is also the author of 16 books including
the one that i mentioned earlier dr
petrucc received his m.a
in religious ethics from yale and a phd
in the same field from the university of
chicago
he is currently associate professor of
theological ethics and serves as a word
on fire institute fellow as well
in addition to numerous articles he is
authored co-authored and co-edited
several books
he's bilingual english spanish and
lectures broadly on topics in ethics the
catholic intellectual tradition and the
intersection between christian theology
and philosophy
so welcome gentlemen thank you very much
for agreeing to speak with me today
and for your careful work as well
so
i guess
i'd like to start by asking you
as i mentioned in the intro
i never
had
really envisioned
being
included in a book
like the one that you just wrote and
i
have noted that a variety of religious
thinkers have
commented on my lectures and work and
i'm wondering why you felt compelled to
put all the time and effort into this i
mean it's a it's a major undertaking to
write a book and so why this book what's
the motivation then
well i
followed closely your lectures on
genesis and
when i was listening to them i was
really fascinated because again and
again i saw
themes that i had read earlier in the
church fathers people like augustine
chrysostom origin
and you were reading scripture according
to
what's called the moral reading of
scripture where you're looking at the
story of say cain and abel and your
primary question isn't was there
actually two brothers someone named kane
and someone named abel you're not so
much looking for the historical facts
you might say in terms of cain and abel
but rather you're looking at that story
in terms of what universal lessons the
story has for us today and that moral
reading of scripture is something that
is very very common in the christian
tradition of
biblical reading and so i thought that
was super interesting and then i also
thought it was interesting how
you were bringing to bear all kinds of
other resources when looking at these
stories so you would bring in
evolutionary um
psychology you'd bring in russian novels
you'd bring in all these things that
would seem to be foreign to the biblical
text but in a way that too was something
that was very traditional in other words
if you look at people like augustine
he'll say that all truth is from god and
so bringing in
any truth from any field is perfectly
legitimate in his view in terms of
trying to understand scripture because
he thinks that god is the ultimate
author of two books the book of
revelation scripture but also the book
of creation so everything in creation
can help inform our understanding of
scripture and scripture can help inform
understanding of creation so
these lectures i really enjoyed them and
it seemed to me that what you were doing
in a certain way was uh reinvale
representing again in a new and fresh
way
the insights that were found in these
older thinkers and the fact that so many
young people especially young people who
call themselves atheists or agnostics or
religious
the fact that so many of these people
were fascinated by our lectures and
drawn to them and as you know so many
comments in on youtube would say things
like i thought the bible was a kind of
stupid old collection of naive stories
totally meaningless for contemporary
life but after hearing your lectures on
genesis now i see how these stories have
perennial
and are extremely important and
insightful for navigating life and so
you know for me what i wanted to do in
the book is both bring out these
resonances with these earlier figures
but also to try to show how these
earlier figures actually in my view
develop
and enhance some of your own insights
and move them further down the road as
it were
so i thought that it would be useful to
bring these reflections together in the
book
yeah i i have the same uh intellectual
reasons as well uh for for engaging your
work uh basically i think we're trying
to speak to two audiences at the same
time one is to your your massive
audience uh to speak
to them
through your work that the ideas that
you've been engaging with such
verve and such power and such clarity uh
not only resonate with the biblical con
context but in fact this is where
from our point of view they find their
fullest expression
uh and so to that audience we want to
see look a little bit deeper look a
little bit broader um we're also
speaking though to to christian
audiences as well to see look at the
work that jordan peterson is doing
perhaps he doesn't see it this way but
he's a serious theologian and he's
opening pathways and opening
modes of communication
that can help us more clearly
communicate some of these biblical
truths as well i also have a personal
reason for it i began watching you
actually i was chris introduced me to
your work and i began watching your work
online um
everything you put out and watch and
what i found so fascinating
is
from from my point of view you exhibit a
lot of the the christian virtue of
courage
and people were attracted to that they
were attracted to hearing truths
including very hard truths
and i thought i wanted i want to dig
deeper to see what what this phenomena
what's been called the jordan peterson
phenomena really is
yeah that it this is a strange thing for
me there's the the popularity of those
biblical lectures i mean it came as a
shock
you know
um
i joked with some people when i first
rented the theater
um in toronto to put the lectures on i
thought i said
if i had gone to
a bank for a loan and told them that my
business plan was to
do 15 two-hour lectures on
on genesis mostly to young men and that
i was going to charge
them to come to a theater and sit
through that
they would have laughed me out of there
because it's such a
preposterous proposition
and yet it seemed to work and the
lectures have been
quite popular online and they've they
seem to have attracted attention from
religious and non-religious people but
basically in the religious vein right
even the atheists who've been watching
are pulled in by the
by by what is essentially the religious
content i guess part of the question is
you know exactly what is that religious
content that's something we could
we could talk about in depth i mean the
fact that my thinking
is influenced by these
church fathers the church fathers and
other historical figures that you
discuss
i guess i get that second hand in some
sense right and probably primarily
through jung carl jung see was
unbelievably educated and i saturated
myself in his
work
and
he was of course
incredibly influenced by the thinkers
that you talk about in the book and so
um and you mentioned
dr kaizor that you know i was putting
old ideas into a new package and
you know that
it's very important to to
to note that that's true is that
you know truly original ally truly
original ideas are very rare
and so
much of what we think of as original is
it's built into the structure of our
culture in ways we don't understand and
then manifests itself within us and
that's certainly the case with these
these biblical stories and i wanted to
make another comment too about truth
you know dr caser you mentioned that i
engage in a moral reading of scripture
say rather than a literalist reading
and maybe we should have a talk about
that because
it isn't easy to read a book like the
bible literally because
it's full of
of literal contradictions
and it whatever it is especially the
really archaic stories in in genesis
whatever it is it's not
it's not history the way we think of
history
and so that's hard for
people it's hard for people to see how
that might still be true
if it's not literal how can it be true
and this is a discussion that i tried to
have with sam harris a lot
because
the atheist types the rationalist types
there's something they miss and what
they miss is that
fiction isn't false it's not a lie
right it's not literal
but it's not a lie and great fiction is
true but it never happened so how can it
be true
and the answer to that is something like
well there are patterns in things deep
patterns
deep recurring patterns
you know human nature the fact that
we're human
that that the humanity itself is a
recurring pattern it has characteristic
shape
and
great fiction
describes the shape of that pattern and
the greatest of fiction the greater
fiction becomes the more it is religious
in nature and
that's not even a
claim about the nature of truth it's
more a claim about the nature of
experience you know when we say
something is profound
what we
mean is that it's moving
and that it has a broad influence it's
capable of having a broad influence on
the way we think and see and act so if
you read a profound book like one of
dostoevsky's books
you could say of that book and people
often do that it changed my life when i
read that book
and
a story that can change your life
has a power that is best described as
religious
and so religious is a kind of experience
in some sense rather
in addition to a claim about what
constitutes truth
and then those stories in genesis
cain and abel i think and the story of
adam and eve because those stories are
so deep that it's almost unfathomable
they
get at the
at the most profound of patterns and so
to say that they're literally true
is actually to massively underestimate
how true they are
because you could tell me what you did
this morning
that would be literally true but like
who cares whereas if you read the story
of adam and eve it's so true that it
applies to everyone always
and mere literal truth can't do that
and we don't have a good language as
scientists let's say as psychologists or
even as citizens
we don't have a good language
for that kind of truth
and so
well i i guess i'd like your thoughts
about that idea
yeah so the the literal sense of
scripture is sometimes misunderstood by
people and i think the the right way to
think of the literal sense of scripture
is what the original human author
intended to convey to the original
human audience and so if we're looking
at genesis i think that we need to put
genesis back in its context if you read
genesis as if it is a contemporary
textbook on science i think what you're
doing is
wrenching it out of its original context
and therefore you're bound to misread it
and that's true of not just genesis it's
really true of any work that to
understand it we need to understand its
genre and we need to understand its
context so what is the original context
of the genesis story well the original
context it was written in terms of rival
stories of creation
other stories that were circulating in
the ancient world and it was meant to be
an answer to those and it uses poetry it
uses imagery and that was what all those
stories did and the poetry in the
imagery i would not set that against
truth as if on the one hand you have
truth in the other hand you have poetry
imagery and story i think that one kind
of truth is scientific truth the
empirically verifiable but i think it's
too narrow to say well the only kind of
truth
is the empirically verifiable i think
truth actually is broader and in fact
that claim that
the only that the truth is empirically
verifiable that's the only kind of truth
that is itself a self-defeating
statement right there's no empirical
evidence that
that the only way to get the truth is
through the empirical method so if we
put genesis back in its context what do
we see well we see it is a story telling
us
about
in contrast to the other stories the
other stories in the ancient world
were stories in which there were
multiple gods
they engaged in a warfare and violence
so you think of the greek myths or like
this where right zeus overthrows his
father and there's all this violence
and genesis is meant to answer
um
these other ancient myths and it's
saying things like there's only one
god
there's not multiple secondly that
creation is not a matter of violence
but that the creation is reasonable
speech and this was something that you
talked about in your lecture which
really struck me because i obviously i'd
read that story before but i never
really thought of it that well creation
awry
right god says let there be light and
there was light and what is reasonable
speech reasonable speech is orderly
right the difference between you know
random sounds you make and reasonable
speech is that there's a kind of order
to it so
if creation arises from reasonable
speech the creation itself is ordered
it's intelligible it makes sense
and
that gives rise centuries and centuries
later that belief that creation is
orderly and makes sense gives rise
centuries later to science
but to read genesis as if it's failed
science it makes about as much chances
to read genesis as if it's you know for
or against
iphones
i mean imagine somebody reading genesis
and they're like well is this should i
buy an iphone or not i'm not going to
read genesis to determine this well
clearly the original author of genesis
wasn't addressing that and the original
author of genesis wasn't addressing for
or against evolution so i think that
that these readers who want to make it
for or against evolution are just
utterly misreading and taking the the
story out of its original context and
therefore
necessarily
providing a really bad reading of
genesis
there's also a really important
theological
point to make here as well and and
that's they can put it philosophically
what's the condition for the possibility
of something being literal
in the first place
what's the condition for the possibility
both of it being recognized spoken
and then apprehended there's a certain
court of orderliness that's necessarily
presupposed in the act of knowing and in
the act of communicating that knowledge
that itself as chris said can't be
empirically verified so when we as
catholics say that that
recognize from the new testament that
jesus is the truth
that would include in a literal
historical sense but also the condition
for the possibility of anything being
intelligible and and literally
understood and communicated at all so i
think one of the the frustrations i
found in finding contemporary debates on
these questions is that secularism
oftentimes isolates and identifies the
literal the empirical as if this is a
freestanding epistemic platform that
belongs to them and everybody has to
compete in order to to be on their
territory and i just don't think that's
philosophically the case it presupposes
a lot of things that that they can't
give an account for yeah i mean so so
one more little yep please go ahead no i
just was just going to add one thing so
imagine somebody was reading
shakespeare's son at 18
right shall i compare thee to a summer's
day that are more lovely and more
temperate
rough winds do shake the darling buds of
may and summer's lease hath all too
short of date so imagine somebody reads
that and they're like okay shakespeare's
a meteorologist she's a weather man and
i'm going to look up in the almanac to
see if may had rough winds and that
turns out there's no rough winds in may
oh shakespeare about it at you know
telling us about the weather well i
think that's a obviously radically
radical misunderstanding of shakespeare
he's not trying to tell us the weather
and then failing to tell us the weather
and so i think genesis is not trying and
failing to give us scientific truths
it's just doing something totally
different and that's part of the reason
i appreciate your lectures is that you
highlighted
the reality that the author of genesis
is trying not to he's trying to
communicate very important truths but
not truths that are in the uh scientific
um
discourse
they're true but not scientific truths
the problem with
the empirical
approach the problem with totalizing it
is that the empirical approach tends to
be mostly
descriptions of things and the way they
interact and the way they can be
manipulated and
and that's fine but it doesn't tell you
doesn't provide any
real insight into how to live how to act
how to take your next step how to
how to produce a hierarchy of values and
how to determine what's most important
and what's least important and
all of that is also
so difficult that we'd actually don't
know how to do it
completely explicitly which is why we
need poetry and drama and literature we
need that whole domain so we could call
that the literary domain
and then i think
you could consider it this might be an
empirical proposition is that
the religious domain is
at the base of the literary domain and
as literature gets deeper
it becomes more and more like religious
writing
and so that by definition in some sense
and i've swiped this in part i would say
from jung is
almost by definition
that the sense of profound engagement
that the most profound literature
produces is what constitutes the
religious
and
that's a domain of experience you know
when you're captivated in a movie
theater when you're captivated by a
story when you're taken outside yourself
none of that has anything to do with
logical argumentation
it's a whole different issue and it to
me it's tied very very deeply
to our ability to imitate and mimic
and so we're really good at that way
better than any other animal we met like
language is mimicry we use the same
words
and so we're mimicking each other and
but i can't mimic
every person separately i have to
extract out from each person some
essence of being that's admirable and i
do that
person after person and i try to imitate
that
and then that core thing that's
admirable that i imitate that's as far
as i'm concerned that's psychologically
equivalent to christ whatever else
christ is christ is
that's why he's sometimes described as
the king of kings
it's like if the king is the thing
that's at the top of the hierarchy and
then you look at all hierarchies and you
take the thing that's at the top of all
hierarchies of value then
that figure when you see reflections of
that figure anywhere
it produces awe and respect
and that's because that pattern
constitutes the appropriate way to act
just as when you see the opposite of
that pattern which might be in its most
fundamental essence satanic or demonic
it's something that's ultimately evil
that produces revulsion and terror and
that's
that's all instinctual it's it's not in
the domain of rationality precisely it's
way way deeper than that
and
the the the eighth and then there's
another problem that the atheists have
never come to terms with
i i believe and you guys tell me what
you think of this is that
if
if what is rendered if what is properly
rendered unto god
is rendered unto caesar
then caesar becomes inflated to god
and when that happens all hell breaks
loose
that's the genesis of totalitarianism
that's
subservience to an idol
and so
and this is a case i think the church
needs to make particularly the catholic
church in the most strenuous of ways is
that
if we don't segregate off the religious
instinct and give it its proper
attention and do which i suppose you do
in part with ritual and church
attendance and so forth then every
single thing we do starts to become
inappropriately contaminated with
religious longing
and that's why you see the rise of
extremely powerful political ideologies
and the division of people you know for
trivial reasons into moral camps it's
that that religious instinct isn't
hasn't got a grounding in it it's
searching for something to attach itself
to and it it picks up second-rate
substitutes you know they people like
dawkins they seem to think that
if we all just abandoned our religious
superstitions we'd all become you know
rationalists like
well like like isaiah newton who was an
alchemist and not a rationalist by the
way
that great genius
and so
one of the things i think that the
catholic church in particular isn't
doing a very good job of is warning
people how dangerous it is
to lose
the proper
theater of expression for our religious
instincts they don't go away
they just get perverted
and they show up all sorts of places
they shouldn't that's that's terrible
it's not good so
yeah that theme is one that augustine
talks about in the city of god he talks
about two loves and he talks about the
love of god and
it creates a certain uh city a certain
organization and if you don't love god
if god is not your ultimate love well
you're gonna love something so it could
be power
it could be pleasure it could be money
it could be status
but augustine thought that if you love
say power
the most well what that's going to do is
it's going to shape you and ultimately
distort not only you but also your
relationships in your society so the
christian view is that ultimately god is
perfect truth love and beauty and so not
only is it the case that worshiping
anything other than that is going to
fail to give god what's due to god and
that's what religion in a sense is about
it's a binding of oneself to god giving
to god what's due but also it ends up
making the person
ultimately unhappy so you can't think
about this even from a psychological
perspective that um people like martin
seligman would say things like
love is at the core of human flourishing
and and if we don't have that if i love
money or power
more than i love god and more than i
love my friends and more than i love my
family well that's going to deprive me
of the source of my
uh my flourishing i'm going to end up
harming myself and characteristically
also harming others when i love power or
money or whatever
too much and so yeah for augustine at
least this is um a perennial temptation
to replace god with something else
that's perhaps
the warning at the end of genesis with
the story of noah and also the story of
the tower of babel
you know because the tower of babel is
people get together and they try to
build an edifice
that
that's absolute in some sense right it's
it's it's a building that's that's under
the control it's an edifice that's of
human manufacture and
it it becomes larger and larger and
larger and then it devolves into a kind
of chaos
and
so with the flood story with knowing the
flood
that's
that's one form of danger that emerges
as a consequence of deviation from the
proper path let's say orientation
towards whatever the highest good is and
the tower of babel is a secondary one
that has more to do with the danger of
of egotistical human construction and it
is something like the worship of these
idols so imagine we can think about this
technically and psychologically in some
sense is that in order to act you have
to presume that that to which you're
moving is more important than where you
are right so you make a value judgment
moving in this direction is appropriate
and then you have to move in a lot of
directions over the course of your life
and and
you know maybe you search for for a
friendship and you search for love and
you search for money and you search for
power and and so forth and
if there's nothing integrating all that
then you're pulled in all sorts of
directions right it's like devil's
pulling you apart because
you don't know what's more important
than
than than what and that's very very
confusing and off-putting and if the
wrong thing takes control then you get
demented and bent
and so what you see in christianity is
this
this struggle over
thousands of years to specify
the thing that should be at the top of
the hierarchy and
one of the things that really opened my
eyes to the depth of these works was
this strange
proclamation that
the word that existed at the beginning
of the time of time that brought
creation into being was the same as
christ which is an unbelievably bizarre
proposition i mean i'm not speaking
about precisely religiously i'm thinking
about it more conceptually it's like
people who had that revelation or
intuition are making the presupposition
that
there's something
about the emergence of
reality into conscious being like
because reality without consciousness
doesn't really seem to exist right so
when we talk about reality we always
presuppose a conscious viewer
and that the conscious viewer that
makes order out of chaos
is
most appropriately the perfect being
that's manifested in the figure of
christ
to
and so that we participate in that
process in some sense
to the degree that we're
attempting to embody that mode of being
so
i i know that's you know that's going
out there in some sense but it struck me
as such a brilliant idea that
it was hard to account for
i don't know if i've made myself clear
with that
well
i i think it
it cuts in many different ways at the
same time but it also cuts directly to
the the previous question that you asked
about the the right domain of religious
expression
and in a sense it's it solves that
problem why well if jesus christ is the
logos on the one hand there means that
means that there is a logos there is a
truth there is a way of existence that
is real which gives us a standard to be
able to identify false ways of being
both individually but also important
politically so it establishes a
groundwork for there to be
an intrinsic limiting principle
politically speaking and morally
speaking to life and that is there is a
truth of the matter and if you're not
living according to the truth you're
you're deviating from it so that
establishes a kind of of ground and
sealing for the proper expression
of of what it means to live morally
individually and also political power as
well you only have right political power
insofar as it conforms to the truth
but the logos is also christ that means
christ is also
the person the historical person that as
catholics we believe is is literally
literally real and literally raised from
the dead and that shows that the
political life is not the sum totality
of life the moral life isn't even the
sum totality of life the some totality
of life is love
in relationship with god who has made
himself incarnate so on the one hand you
have the foundation of truth to to
structure and limit
human life and then its ultimate
transcendent tale or purpose
dr kaiser you got some comments about
that
i did i wanted to circle back to you
said if i heard you correctly that
reality doesn't exist without
consciousness
and i think that's true if if god exists
but then if god doesn't exist then it's
not true so human beings of course
haven't been on planet earth since the
beginning of the universe the universe
is about 13.8 billion years old so say
12 billion years ago there are no human
beings at all and presumably there was
no consciousness at all so there was
reality there were
the beginning of stars and things like
that but there was no conscious beings
anywhere that that you know was able to
understand that unless god exists now if
god exists and if it's true that god
um is the the logos well then he would
say from all eternity
um there was consciousness there was a
mind there was a divine mind and so
and on that view there actually would be
an ultimate unity you might say
in terms of
the divine essence in the divine mind
ultimately being one so consciousness
and existence
have this fundamental
ground in in god but if god doesn't
exist then i think what you said would
not be true because again 12 billion
years ago there's no human beings around
presumably unless there are aliens
there's no one around to be conscious
and so there would have been reality say
12 billion years ago but there there
wouldn't have been consciousness yeah so
i want to go out on a limb here too
because
i have a problem with that i can't shake
this
the supposition that our
scientific cosmological theories
have an implicit conscious observer
nested inside of them even when they
claim not to
so for example
when you talk about 13 billion years ago
there's there's
i don't know how to say this properly
this the
the concept of 13 billion years seems to
me to require a conscious observer to
formulate to begin with because i don't
understand
what duration consists of in the absence
of something experiencing duration it's
like how does something last 13 billion
years
like in some sense it all happens at
once if there's no conscious observer
like there's
i
i know well it would depend it would
depend right on the nature of time so
the view you're talking about was
actually put forth by a guy named
barclay and he said to be
is to be perceived so in other words if
you don't have a perceiver there just
wouldn't be any being at all but i don't
think that that is that's right i mean i
think you're right that the idea or the
concept the human concept of time
obviously that can't exist without human
beings but before there were any human
beings it seems that all available
scientific evidence suggests that there
were
things there was carbon molecules and
there were stars and there was all kinds
of things that existed before there was
any conscious human
uh perceiving them so it is true of
course that all of our evidence for the
big bang and all of our scientific
investigations presuppose conscious
observers that are
you know taking the measurements and
things like that but i'm not sure it
follows from that logically that
therefore
we
can't with good reason hold that things
existed before there are any human or or
for that matter any kind of conscious
observers
unless we think berkeley is right that
to be is to be perceived well
there's something in berkeley's
objection that that that seems to me to
be
hard to skate around like
when we
imagine
time before consciousness and we imagine
the existence of objects before
consciousness we imagine them as if a
conscious observer was there even though
there wasn't one so we think like we see
a star from a particular level of
resolution right we can't see subatomic
particles um we can't see
atomic structures we can't see molecular
structures
that
that which exists before there's a
perceiver is all those levels
simultaneously
at once
with a duration that doesn't with a with
a temporal sequence that doesn't involve
duration
and so it
whatever was there before there was a
perceiver is in some sense unimaginable
without the projection of a perceiver
back into time
and i think that warps our
perspective
on what it was that's there and perhaps
our perspective on the role of
consciousness in the genesis of being
so
anyways that's those are
here's another another way of thinking
about it and i don't know what your view
would be so let's say god forbid
uh there's some sort of plague that
strikes humanity and all human beings
die
on my view there would still be lots of
things that continue to exist like the
sun would still exist the earth would
still exist there'd be all kinds of
things that exist now there'd be no
human beings in that terrible scenario
that were there to perceive it but they
would still continue to exist
or maybe you have a different view
i just
so imagine that consciousness was
eradicated say not just human beings
just to make it cleaner in some sense
the
i can't understand how to conceptualize
what it is that would be left
you know is it is it nothing but quantum
potential
is it the sea of quantum potential
is it not turned into stars and solar
systems and galaxies when there's an
observer or specifying a level of
analysis
it isn't obvious to me from looking at
the physics what it is that's there see
because you say well there'd still be a
sun it's like well
wait a
second when you think of the sun you
think of what you perceive and when you
say it would still be there you think
that what you perceive would still be
there but you're not there so what you
perceive would not be there i don't know
what it is that would be there you could
say it's as if the sun is still there
but
but the the level of analysis problem
and the fact of
the strange constituent
uh reality of matter at the at the
quantum level
makes it very difficult for me to
conceive of a universe that's just the
same as it is now
except there's no conscious observer it
doesn't make sense to me
it if it may briefly it seems to me that
there's perhaps some equivocation in in
the in the use of the word existence
here
um because existence is of course tied
up with duration uh understood from our
own perception of it but that doesn't
necessarily mean that duration is the
is either a necessary uh condition for
existence or uh or the most important
condition so we think of existence uh in
terms of of other potential qualities
that it has unity following a kind of
pattern
and in in that sense it seems to me the
more more important question isn't what
would existence be like if there were no
observers but would there be existence
and i think it's it's logically possible
metaphysically perhaps even necessary to
say that there would be existence but
that doesn't mean that we would be able
to
describe it
yeah so i think i'm going to disagree
with you now um i'm not sure there would
be if there was no
if there were no perceivers at all um
including god
then i don't think there could be other
existing things well i would think i
mean human perspective okay i was
limited to that yeah because if because
if aquinas is right
there there couldn't be anything at all
right in existence
if god wasn't the ultimate first cause
of all these things and so if god didn't
exist at all that would mean that there
couldn't be anything else if he's right
about this whole argument i mean i think
he is right so
um so there is ultimately a
uh mind perceiving all created reality
the divine mind but i don't think there
needs to be human minds or for that
matter if they're you know if we talk
about angels i don't think there needs
to be angelic minds for there to be
existing things
yeah well i i guess i'm i'm i'm stuck on
this for
for
reasons that i think are somewhat
scientific in in their nature
my inability to conceptualize what it is
that would be if there is no point of
reference because everything is all
things at once in some sense without a
limited without a delimited observer
and so i don't know what it is for there
to be something when everything is
everything at once
there's no differentiation as a
consequence of a limited observer so but
we can we can we can leave that
that part of the argument i'm pushing
this at least in some part because
i i
i have also seen i would say on the part
of the more dedicated modern atheists
this
necessity to
devalue consciousness
consciousness seems to be
it's a mystery let's put it that way and
it's it's an unexplained mystery and
it's given such
pronounced status in the biblical
writings it's part of what gives human
beings dignity is the fact that we share
this logos consciousness that's
integrally tied up with the structure of
reality as such
and
well yes i'll just leave it at that
that's enough exploration of that as far
as i'm concerned um
one of the
another thing that we might talk about
briefly is that
there's also
a tendency in
the modern culture
as we move away from
our religious heritage as fewer few
fewer people go to church let's say and
are even familiar with the traditional
church writings
to swallow this story that
science and religion have been at odds
with one another throughout the course
of history and dr petrasek you made a
case earlier in this discussion
i believe it was you
that
the
proposition that the world was
ordered by something
that was akin to
a comprehensible intelligence
or an intelligence or a consciousness
that we could have a relationship with
was the deep felt sense that
we could understand things if we
investigated them and
that's
means that the religious proposition of
an orderly comprehensible world amenable
to the investigations of consciousness
was actually a precondition for the dawn
of science and that's what nietzsche
claimed us nietzsche claimed that
christianity died at its own hands by
emphasizing
the
the uh
what would you say the primary
importance of truth
and so
the exploration of truth at least in
part developed into the empirical domain
and then the scientific worldview
produced
representations of being that seemed to
contradict the traditional
representations
and because
our minds had been trained to value
truth to such a great degree
at least in part as a consequence of our
religious education
we
were
forced by logical consistency in some
sense to experience this existential
crisis that
the apparent opposition between the
empirical and the religious has put us
into
so that's a different reading of the
relationship between science and
religion
it means it's a problem we have to solve
instead of a battle between two
opponents one of whom has to win and the
other
whom has to lose
yeah well that completely uh contradicts
the certainly the the catholic
understanding the relationship between
science and and religion there's a
historical question here which is
how did science emerge into its current
form and even even on those grounds it's
inaccurate to say that that christianity
and specifically catholicism has ever
been opposed to science
uh
the historical record just just doesn't
show that then there's a conceptual and
philosophical question of again using
the philosophical language
what's the condition for the possibility
of there being
a empirical investigation insofar as
it's it's
cognitively and epistemically possible
and then the motivational question of
why in the world would you carry it out
unless you you have the belief either
explicitly or implicitly that the world
both is knowable and that that knowledge
is somehow real
that presupposes not only any generic
metaphysics but i would i would say a
specifically christian metaphysic in
particular so it's it's a meme i would
say that science and religion are
somehow opposed but it's it's it's a
false one
the idea that
science and religion are opposed
arose really in the 19th century there
was a guy named draper and he wrote a
book that they basically put forward
this thesis and
and before that the thesis wasn't held
and there's no real good historical
grounds for for holding that so if you
look at many of the
uh prominent scientists in the history
of science many of them were
faithful believing people i mean newton
uh was a faithful protestant you have
people like descartes catholic you have
blaise pascal a great
mathematician you have uh gregoire
mendel you have um george lemaitre in
the 20th century who was one of the
founders of big bang cosmology so all
the way from the beginning of science to
today you have prominent people of faith
that are that are scientists even right
now i think the head of the
what is it the head of the national
institute for health i think francis i
forget his name but anyway he's a
prominent believer
and the church as an institution
also supported science so the cathedrals
were designed in the 17th century to
serve also as solar observatories uh
catholic universities all around the
world
have departments of science and promote
scientific investigation for their
students
the pope has a pontifical academy for
science he invites scientists from all
over the world scientists of
all different faiths and no faith to
come to the vatican for these scientific
meetings so i think it's really quite
unfair to say the church is opposed to
science so faith and science are
obviously not the same thing there's
people that are great at science that
don't have faith there are people that
are great at faith and don't know much
about science but there are people that
are kind of overlapping and so i think
it is really
yeah a myth to think that the church is
opposed to science yeah i just have very
very briefly it's not a biographical
peculiarity that that these these great
uh people of science who are catholics
they they didn't practice their their
scientific craft in addition to
believing in god and practicing
catholicism they they did it precisely
as catholic working from the the
framework of faith and reason there and
that that's always that's always been
the case
so nis
let's let's delve into this faith issue
a bit too
because the faith is a very complicated
term and
you know it's often
parodied
but by the rationalists you know
to have faith in god
is
parodied as a
like a
primitive and superstitious
belief
but
my psychological investigations
convinced me that
there's no action without faith
because we are always stepping into the
unknown
we have to take a leap of faith to
exist
to do the simplest of things to
literally to move and that has to do
with what i said earlier is that
we're trying to move from a place of
less value to a place of more value
so we have to make some assumptions
about what constitutes value
and then we have to believe that our
actions are going to have the outcome
that we desire
and we do that without evidence i mean
that's partly why to be human is to be
riven with anxiety it's because there's
no certainty and so
you can't act without faith and so then
the question might if you accept that
proposition you can't act without faith
and i actually believe i don't believe
that that's a
disputable
proposition unless you view people as
deterministic in the way that clocks are
you know so that we're just stimulus
response machines it seems to me that
instead we're moving into the unknown
and we do that
in dread in some sense dread and hope
and we do that because we have faith and
when we lose that faith our lives fall
apart
and and we don't know which way is up or
down and so then the question is well if
we have to have faith
what is it that we should have faith in
and then the answer seems to be
something like well we should have
if we have to make a decision about that
maybe we try to have faith in what in in
the idea that the best should be pursued
and will prevail
as an organizing principle and then the
question is well what is the best and
the answer is well that's really hard
question and so we need cathedrals and
we need box music and we need the
stories in genesis and we need the
world's great literature and we need all
of that
theater and drama and art and aesthetics
to help us understand what the best is
and to determine how it should prevail
and i don't see that technically as any
different from
i think it is the same thing
psychologically
as the worship of christ
i think it's the same thing
because
again i'm trying to speak
psychologically to think about what
christ represents i'm not thinking about
him as a historical figure that's
something we can get to later
that image
which is seen for example
laid out on these massive cathedral
domes
christ as logos as as generator of the
world it's
it's the idea that the proper mode of
being is brought into existence by
consciousness that's operating according
to the highest possible principles
and like why wouldn't
and that is the kind of faith that's
maybe got some courage associated with
it right i'm going to act as if this is
the case we're all going to act as if
this is the case
now that begs the question does that
make it real well
that's a harder question
yeah saint anselm
thought about god as that than which
nothing greater can be conceived
so he thought of god as the highest
perfect good in aquinas too thought of
god in a similar way is absolute
perfection
and i would say that this kind of faith
though can be reasonable
it's not in my view at least a kind of
blind
shot in the dark that you're just
wandering around and you just kind of
make things up i think there's actually
good philosophical reasons to think that
there does have to be
a first cause there does have to be a
necessary being and aquinas puts forward
these arguments and people have i myself
have
talked about these things to my students
and on and online there's it's not just
a a shot in the dark as it were so
but i think you're right that people do
need faith in some sense just to live
just to move forward but i do think that
you might say specifically theistic
faith is something that's very
reasonable you think of people like
william lane craig who has devoted a
considerable amount of his time to
exploring the kalam
cosmological argument
and
i don't know if you're familiar with
that argument but it's it's quite simple
it just says that oh you're not so
it says that
whatever begins to exist
has a cause
that's the major premise and then the
minor premise is the universe began to
exist
and therefore the universe has a cause
and by universe what's meant in the
argument is all time
all space and all matter
and so if the universe has a cause
that's prior to time it must be
something that is timeless
or you might say eternal if the cause of
the universe is the cause of all matter
it must be prior to matter it must be
immaterial
if the cause of the universe brought the
whole universe into existence obviously
the cause of the universe has to be
immensely powerful
and so you have say in the
cosmological argument the cosmological
argument an argument a reason to believe
that god exists and you know we can talk
about whether that argument works but
you also have other arguments like the
fine-tuning argument and i read online
that you were looking at the god
hypothesis and as you know from reading
that book there is a lot of very solid
evidence
that the universe is fine-tuned and then
if you're going to explain that
fine-tuning in terms of chance
the likelihood of that is unbelievably
unlikely it'd be like if i won the
lottery every single day of my whole
life
it's much more unlikely
that the universe could have been
brought about by chance and still been
able to have life in it so i think that
that to believe in god is very much a
reasonable faith it's not just a random
arbitrary uh
you know wishful thinking kind of kind
of view
yeah i would add that that
i i think i'm hearing two different
kinds of faith at the same time that
ultimately i believe can be in fact the
teaching of the catholic church that
they they are united and that's we call
faith one faith one could be defined as
as what must be
in existence and true in order for there
to be anything else in existence and
true and as you were putting it jordan
how do we make any kind of decision
based upon any kind of evidence
whatsoever whether it's in terms of
empirical matters whether it's term
immoral matters there's so many
presuppositions that we can't make
arguments about but that must be true in
order for us to make arguments about
anything so that's the horizon as it
were of faith and we can't not have
faith in that sense but then as you put
it then then it raises the question what
do we have faith in
well the the catholic answer to that and
the christian answer to that in its
broadest possible sense is you have
faith in jesus christ jesus christ is
the logos is the totality of who god is
that horizon of meaning the horizon of
intelligibility and that whom you can
ultimately trust that's the second
meaning of faith which is not really an
epistemic category it presupposes an
epistemic category which is belief but
it's multiply about trust who do you
most trust and it's the options there
are really quite limited either you're
going to trust something in the world
you're going to trust yourself or you're
going to trust god
and anything in the world and yourself
you'll be let down guaranteed you'll be
let down disastrously in fact
so the third option
is you trust christ who through
revelation we see loves you infinitely
so in that in that sense christ once
again solves the problem of faith both
at its beginning and it's at its end
okay so let let's
delve into that again so
i mentioned that
earlier when we were talking that
you could conceptualize christ
psychologically as
the re
the representation of all things that
strike us as admirable
so
you can so here's an example you know
when i used to watch my kids play house
my son would play the father and my
daughter would play the mother
and she would
act out being a mother and you might say
well she was imitating my wife
but she wasn't because
she wasn't copying her exactly because
you know my wife would walk across the
kitchen in a particular way and
and
pick up
a plate and bring it to the table in a
particular way like they were to copy
that is to duplicate it exactly with
your body right which i could do if i
was imitating you
something you'd find very annoying
anyways what the child does
is something quite different
they
they watch the father across time and
they watch the mother across time and
they extract out
those elements of perception and action
that can be imitated that constitute the
spirit of the mother and the spirit of
the father and then that's what they
manifest in their play
and so they're doing that at a very very
early age it's not direct mimicry
it's me it's as if they've
they're working out the story of what
it's like to be a father and they're
acting that out now they use
their
observations of their actual father to
fill in that
play
space that imaginative space but they
also get information from
movies and television and all the books
they've been read and all of that is
feeding their
embodiment of the father
and so and this isn't something that's
rational exactly so let's say the child
as a consequence of this felt sense of
admiration
focuses on a particular attribute in a
book watches the hero of the story
and is compelled to incorporate that
into their representation
and so
they're trying to act out what's
admirable and then faith in that sense
is
what is it
is it willingness to act out the
proposition that
what we find admirable will in fact be
the most appropriate guide to how we
should act in the world
because you have the child acting out
the father but then there would be the
set of all fathers and then there would
be what was extracted out of that that
would be
the ultimately admirable ideal
which is
like god brought to earth if if god is
that which no greater can be imagined
and then that's embodied which is the
christian idea
then what's most admirable
is embodied in the figure of christ and
that's
the thing to imitate and the faith isn't
belief that that's real i don't believe
that the faith is
willingness to act out of the world
that's a different thing because i we
make this propositional too much i don't
think it is
yeah
it
because the imitate is the imitation of
christ
not only propositional oh sir
sorry everyone there's a bit of a lag on
our connection so that's why we're
awkwardly interrupting one another so
please go ahead i think i
i i would say that it's it's not only
propositional and in fact
on a final analysis the propositional
components of the faith may be the the
least important i would say they're
they're necessary but certainly not
sufficient
but as you're describing your conception
of faith the the word that that really
uh stuck out for me is is that this that
this will happen that i act according to
a belief or to an intuition
uh that
if i act a certain and according to a
certain kind of pattern that i will
realize the
uh the the nature of the the pattern
itself
i think that's certainly part of it from
a christian perspective it absolutely is
it has to be because it's metaphysically
the case that god created
all things good and so this pattern is
embedded absolutely everywhere in
creation including in the human mind
including in the human soul
however there's the the problem of sin
right we live in a world that is
radically fallen starting with the the
broken natures of our own selves and so
the will there
is not just the question is do i have
any reason to believe that my acting
according to this pattern will act will
actually bring about the the desired
outcome that i hope for and that's where
jesus christ moves from being the
teacher
who
not only gives the pattern but
instantiates the pattern to the savior
because the reality is no you will i
will not i will fail and again fail
disastrously so it is only because this
archetype of moral truth and goodness is
actually
willing to reach into my life into our
lives that that will actually can have
any meaning and and really
command any kind of belief that's why i
believe is because it's not just a
pattern that i'm seeking to conform to
it's a person who's reaching out to me
it's both so if that's the case then why
is it necessary for us to strive to be
good
like what role does our moral striving
play
because it's the same reason i would
strive to be a good husband
uh and not only in a generic sense that
i have a certain set of of criteria that
this is what defines being a good
husband is and so therefore i'm going to
act to it sort of duty bound say again
duty is necessary but not sufficient i
act out of love so i seek to be good
because i love that he who who loves me
and again at that point duty is it it
ruins the story it ruins the
relationship it's i am loved and i wish
to love and i recognize i will fail time
and time again
but i love because
i love he who loves me and and and and
conversely that's also what leads to my
ultimate happiness so
i i think i think one thing that's that
is
could could really complete a lot of the
a lot of the theological reflections in
your work more broadly is is a
conception of grace
um a lot of the christianity i see
in terms of its in its ideas and your
work is a christianity without grace now
grace we have to define very carefully
but at the end of the day a christianity
without grace is not christianity
one distinction that might help our
conversation is the distinction between
a living faith and dead faith so for
a living faith what that is is a faith
that is
enlivened by charity and it's a faith in
which god's own love sort of works
through me god's love is in me and i
express god's love to others now we say
well why do we need to worry about being
good i mean if if
jesus is doing all the work then you
know i can just do whatever i want but
part of the answer would be
that for me to have a living faith i
have to maintain that connection with
god
so
it's possible to just as it is with a
human relationship it's possible to
damage a relationship in a kind of minor
way but it's also possible to damage a
relationship in a really deadly way so
that our friendship is just over in
virtue of me punching him in the face or
doing something just terrible and the
same thing would be true for god that we
have this relationship with god or we
can but it's possible for us to so
damage to that relationship that we no
longer have living faith the best we
could have is the dead faith i believe
in a proposition that god exists
and you know maybe that informs me in
certain ways but basically i don't have
a living faith at all
and so
the the things i do can't be an
expression ultimately of my union with
god that spills over into loving other
people because in the catholic view
jesus is
the ultimate pattern you might say but
the ultimate pattern is
becomes part of our lives through us
being united with him
so there's different metaphors used in
scripture like he's the vine and you are
the branches and
uh he is the head and you were part of
his body
uh but another beautiful way of thinking
about it and i just ran across this in a
book called christ alive in me by this
jesuit priest father david mcconey and
it was a great kind of analogy and it he
said imagine as if god is a sort of
burning furnace and then you're like the
hot iron that's put in this furnace and
kind of heat it up well the the heat and
the light from that fire gets into
the iron and you take it out of the fire
and it's still like lit up and it's
still super hot because the heat has
kind of gotten inside and so in the
christian view
we are
in this relationship and we want to as
it were let god inside and then
hopefully god
remains in us we don't kick god out i
mean god wouldn't leave of his own
accord but we can kick him out through
serious serious wrongdoing but hopefully
that light and that fire
makes us more alive and makes us able to
give some of that light and that fire to
other people who are
in need other people that need god's
mercy and they they need god's help so
it's not just a teacher-student kind of
relationship that i that jesus is a
little bit like socrates i mean i love
socrates i love aristotle they are
absolutely terrific but the idea of
jesus is beyond
just a good teacher beyond just a good
example but that the life of jesus would
actually live in
in you and so this is called by
different names sometimes it's called
theosis deification sanctifying grace
these are all kind of
different terms for the same idea but
the basic idea is that the heat and the
light of god
becomes part of you and then hopefully
you're able to
make the world a better place and be a
better husband be a better father be a
better friend be a better professor you
can do the things you do in a new way
because you have this this light and
this heat within you
uh two two more questions if you don't
mind let's let's let's talk about
the evolution issue
i mean
it looks to me like the story of
creation in genesis and the story of
adam and eve
is in large part
a description of
the role of consciousness in being
i mean
the idea that
the the beginning itself is associated
with the dawn of light it's
it's like the experience of the day of
the morning sun it's that things spring
into being and so
there's some illusion to consciousness
itself there and then
the fall of adam and eve seems to
involve something like the development
of
self-consciousness
and so
that's one way of
conceptualizing creation and the human
role in it and and maybe our fallen
state to some degree as well as the
corrupting influence of
self-consciousness and the terror that
it that it generates
it's it's difficult to square that
account
in some sense with theories of evolution
and i'm curious about how
you two manage that like
you're you're both and may correct me if
i'm wrong but you both accept the broad
outlines of modern cosmology and
evolutionary theory
and so
how do you see
the
christian narrative
how do you see it in in in juxtaposition
with that i mean that was certainly a
problem for darwin
i mean it just about drove him out of
his mind so
so in the catholic tradition there is a
long history of reading genesis uh in a
way that's sensitive to its context so
there are some readers like saint ansa i
mean
ambrose who did hold for instance that
the seven days of creation were seven
24-hour periods but most catholic
interpreters augustine
thomas aquinas john paul ii
pope francis don't interpret it in that
sort of way so i think genesis is
teaching us very very important truths
but it's not teaching us about
contemporary science so i would say it's
not for or against evolution it's just
not
trying to to do contemporary science so
what is it trying to do well it's trying
to teach us important truths and you
have in your lectures explored a number
of those
important truths but but here's another
truth that at least i think is quite
significant in terms of
the genesis story
if we take the genesis story as a
poetic and
imagery filled kind of narrative one of
the points i think is that all human
beings ultimately are part of one human
family
that is say everyone on planet earth i
should treat as if they are distantly a
brother or sister of mine
and if you look at some of the other
rival stories of creation if you look at
for instance uh plato's symposium he has
a story there that is spoken by
aristophanes and aristophanes in that
story says well human beings arose from
three different sources some arose from
the sun some arose from the moon some
arose from
the earth and so we all come from these
different places and on that on that
view right ultimately other human beings
are literally could be from a different
planet and so
you know there's ethical consequences
for that if we really took seriously the
idea
that all human beings
are part of one human family that is i
think a revolutionary idea in centuries
and centuries later that idea was
developed into this idea that we still
have of human rights right the idea of
human rights is that every single human
being regardless of race religion age it
doesn't matter
all human beings
deserve fundamental respect in other
words you might say all human beings are
part of one human family we're all equal
in dignity and so we should be respected
so i think genesis is teaching us
incredibly important truths
like that truth that we should respect
all human beings as part of one human
family but i do think it's a mis reading
of genesis to um to look to genesis as
if it's a science textbook just like we
wouldn't look to genesis you know to
again i mentioned this earlier we
wouldn't look to genesis to find answers
about well should i buy an iphone or
should i buy an android phone like
that's just genesis isn't trying to do
that it's not for or against iphones
it's just not about iphones and so
genesis just isn't for or against
evolution it's it's it's just not
talking about that kind of thing at all
yeah i i would just say i think i think
the root question
the more important question both morally
and metaphysically
with regards to evolution and
god and existence is is is existence
arbitrary or not
is life accidental or not
is there any way in which we can
identify that the symbols and patterns
that we see in the world both
empirically scientifically and
bringing in some of your thought jordan
morally are those ultimately our own
creations our own anxious creations in
order to try and cope with an existence
that is neither here nor there
and and therefore just as arbitrary as
anything else or are they real and i and
i i know the question of the real is at
the one hand the hardest question to
answer um but on the other hand it's the
most important question to answer that's
the root question for me with regards to
evolutionary theory
um
do i accept the broad contours of it yes
saint john paul ii uh
a previous pope has
wrote in support of its the general idea
that life can involve
but the root question again is does god
exist and did god create the universe
how that happened the mechanism by which
that took place is an incredibly
important question for scientific
analysis but it's a secondary question
to whether or not god exists and
therefore there is meaning purpose order
and structure in existence
so let maybe we'll
i definitely want to ask this question
so it's become increasingly difficult
for the
catholic church
perhaps in particular in the west to
attract young people
i don't think that's a statement that
anyone would disagree with but people
are watching my biblical lectures
and lots of them are young and they came
to the lectures
so
why is that exactly what's going on
there
i mean i don't know how to understand it
precisely
and i can't work it out in my own mind
you're looking at it in some sense from
the outside
what
what's the story there
uh i think part of it's a just a
sociological cultural question where in
the minds of many young people perhaps
most people religion is an
undifferentiated mass
and what religion means is
basically what the the technical term
would be feedism that you believe
something that you have no rational
reason to believe
and you've just embraced it as a matter
of kind of a personal mantra but
otherwise it's completely irrational i
think in most young people's minds
that's the case so the the general trend
we see within catholicism is more the
specific trend we see within catholicism
more just a general trend of people
leaving uh religion and i think why why
your work has been so important for
those of us who
who are who are catholics
is that
you are showing that that's not what
religion is now we can have very
important and timely questions about why
the catholic church hasn't been
doing its duty as it were we're part of
the word on fire institute and that's
that's precisely what we're seeking to
do that's precisely the the mission of
the word on fire institute um but your
work has re-established that connection
for
millions of people who have a false idea
one of religion generally but two of of
christianity and catholicism in
particular
yeah i think that's right so part of
your lecture
lectures i think are showing
a dialogue between faith and reason
because obviously you have the you have
the scientific background your professor
of psychology and you know about the
empirical science and all kinds of
things but you're also taking these
questions of faith seriously so for us
that is really bread and butter part of
the
catholic tradition so there are
definitely are some forms of religion
even some forms of christianity they
will want to pit faith against reason as
if faith and reason are in an mma fight
and they're you know going at it and
they're going to you know choke each
other out and well on our view that's
not true on our view god is the ultimate
source of both faith and reason so john
paul ii put it in a very beautiful way
he said that faith and reason are two
wings that the human person uses to fly
up towards the truth and so the idea is
that there's a kind of harmony they're
different right your left wing's not the
same as your right wing these are two
different things but they are not set at
odds with each other
they're in harmony so you see this sort
of
harmony and figures like augustine who
wants to combine a kind of platonic
philosophy
with a christian wisdom and then you
find a different kind of synthesis in
someone like thomas aquinas who wants to
combine an aristotelian philosophy with
a christian wisdom and then you find a
similar sort of combining in many other
figures in the christian tradition john
henry newman john paul ii etc and so
i think in a way one way to interpret
your work is as
another
way of bringing together faith and
reason in this in this conversation in
this dialogue and it's certainly part of
the work i try to do as a professor of
philosophy i mean some people say oh
you're a professor of philosophy you're
supposed to be you know how could you be
catholic
and i think that question is nonsensical
if you understand the catholic view of
faith and reason that faith and reason
are not on our view
you know opposed they're working
together they're in harmony
and part of the intellectual adventure i
think is is talking about these
questions and bringing these two sources
into fruitful conversation
in a very basic sense
faith cannot oppose reason
because if god is and god is one
then any truth whatever form formulation
that truth is taking it cannot be
opposed to itself this is a fundamental
principle in the thought of saint thomas
aquinas and so any statement that would
be irrational
we as catholics would reject but faith
is
supra-rational and we talked about this
early in the conversation right there's
a sense in which there's a there's a
there's an invisible but real foundation
to reason itself both logic and
empirical observation and then there's a
destination for where it's headed so in
that sense faith is is never against
reason but it's the condition for the
possibility and the purpose of reason
so part of it you think is is this
demonstration of the coexistence and
maybe the necessary coexistence or the
optimal coexistence of faith and reason
but there's maybe there's another aspect
to a couple other aspects and
like
maybe
this might be a consequence of
the empirical revolution in human
thought is that
maybe the modern church has concentrated
too much on
emphasizing the propositional
at the expense of the
enacted
and i could see that happening a little
bit in our conversation you know so
i i'm trying to find places to stand
that are really solid and like the idea
that we have an instinct to admire
and that we can extract out the pattern
of what's admirable and that we can then
deify that and assume a relationship
between that and the ultimate ideal that
seems
very solid to me
i kind of i don't feel
any
internal disunity about those
propositions
that's different about those
suppositions let's say
that's different than the claim that you
know there was a god who exists outside
of time and space and who created the
universe
that that's more like
a set of
statements that you need to believe
whereas the first set is
a set of
answers to questions that everybody has
you know and and
maybe that's
see i was trained as a behavioral
psychologist
i was trained
as a cognitive behavioral psychologist
but i concentrated more on the
behavioral element the
how to help people change the way they
act and to make that central
and i i try to do that in my lectures
it's like well you know everybody needs
to know how to act no one disputes that
the audience doesn't dispute that and
then figuring out how to act is a great
mystery and
we all seem to be guided by our
conscience and we can't escape that
conscience even though we might like to
and we all seem to have some sense that
some things are good and other things
are evil and
so what's good and is that what we
should pursue and how is that
represented
those are all solid questions and there
are solid religious answers to them
but then
there are these
more abstract propositions
that seem to make that people bounce off
them and young people bounce off them
because they're more like
a set of
they're like an insistence about what
you must believe propositionally rather
than answers to questions about how to
walk through life given this the
questions about life mysteries that you
all have in your head
and it's the latter that i'm
trying to explore and address in the
lectures you know
and i think that's partly why people are
find them
acceptable you know they don't just
bounce off them and say well that's
religious claptrap i'm done with that
you know and reject them the same way
they do
at least to some degree
you know church attendance and
i'm always mute i'm always exploring a
mystery with the audience in my lectures
you know when
i'm not telling them what i believe
i don't even tell them what i believe to
be true because i'm always questioning
what i believe and
the reason i keep insisting on this in
this conversation is because it is
really is something i'm trying to solve
it's like
what is the
i do believe that we are in danger of
making all sorts of things religious
that shouldn't be and that that's going
to do our culture great damage
and that unless we put god back in god's
place and caesar back in caesar's place
things are going to
be grim
and i the church the classical church
the catholic church has to play a role
in that but
it i don't see it
i don't see a tremendous amount of
evidence that that's happening among
young people so i'm not saying that with
any sense of glee obviously
it's it's it's a mystery that needs to
be solved
and so
yeah i think you're right that your
lectures focus more on the existential
and the practical and how to live this
out
and i think that's really important and
in the catholic church at least part of
what we do
is actually offer
young people a chance to do that so for
instance at every catholic university in
every catholic parish there's all kinds
of
outreach programs there's all kinds of
ways in which we're trying to live out
this christian message because at the
end of the day i think you're right the
living it out is
so essential and so important
on the other hand i think when you're
living out something there is at least
implicitly
some sort of theoretical
view that you're living out that is to
say if i live out a life of greed right
at least implicitly i am saying as it
were
at least in my actions that i think that
money is the most important thing
and so in a way the theory
i think you're absolutely right just the
theory is what i would have called
earlier dead faith of course that
doesn't help at all we need living faith
but i do think that a living faith is
not going to live very long unless there
is at least some
intellectual content to it and the
reason for that is that human beings
have minds and they ask questions and so
if people are asking questions and you
know my students in philosophy class ask
questions all the time
and there's no answer at all
then i think that leaves the the
practice of faith being uh kind of
unmoored and being kind of shallow so i
think you're 100 right like if i could
say for my kids would i rather have them
have all kinds of theories and all kinds
of abstract ideas and be an expert in
theology and philosophy
but in their real life
they don't worship god they don't serve
people in need they're a horrible friend
etc or the reverse well of course i'd
rather have them living a life of
charity and and the virtues and being a
great person even if their intellectual
understanding was sort of thin
but i do think you know given that
people ask questions and people ask
other people questions i think if
there's no intellectual content what can
happen really easily is it it just sort
of evaporates right that is to say that
you you give up going you give up
worship you give up service you give up
thinking that people that are different
from you deserve fundamental respect you
sort of
the practices end up
going away i think unless there's at
least some intellectual
um
substance there and then partly depends
on your person person like who you are
so
i'm someone who really loves to read
books i love to talk about intellectual
things so for me that's a big part of my
life now there are other people who are
great people who you know they don't
read books and they don't like talking
about issues and
fair enough i mean not everyone's not
everyone's alike but i do think there
are lots of young people that ask
intellectual questions
right they ask well how do you fit
genesis with evolution
and if you just sit there and go i have
no idea i just just believe
well you could do that but at least for
us as catholics we don't we're not
fetish we don't say oh just believe it
there's no explanation we try to provide
reasonable explanations of things but
but i do think i do agree with you at
the end of the day
living charity is the most important and
it's something that saint paul talked
about
right if you give your body over to be
burned if you have faith to move
mountains
but you don't have love
right it's all worthless
and so love at the end of the day is
the most important
yeah i think i think an important
distinction here is is
what's necessary and what's most
important they're not always the the
same thing so what's necessary in order
for
catholicism to become catholicism it
must have a set must have dogma right or
else it's it's it's not anything
whatsoever so in so far as the catholic
church has dogma we have a set of
propositions that we believe in many
sets of propositions that we believe to
be true in every way that something can
be true
historically
metaphorically literally morally all
these things we believe to be true so
that's necessary but that's necessary
for any group it's necessary for any
individual in order to have any kind of
unified personality so in that sense
it's absolutely necessary is it the most
important no no but but that again the
most important is that these dogmas as
chris has been put it become alive
become alive as saint paul also puts it
without without love you are a like a
gong that makes no sound whatsoever and
so one of the critiques that i've that
has really hit home that you that you've
also made in in previous videos is that
catholicism is not calling its people to
be heroes
that that that sticks with me i think i
think that's right and we we have within
our faith what's called the doctrine of
the saints which in a very basic sense
just means that we believe that there
are people just like us
who have lived in a way that exhibits
what it truly means to be a follower of
jesus christ
and if you look at the different kinds
of saints what you will find is
vastly different kinds of personalities
vastly different kinds of interests but
two things will also be present one
courage
and two fidelity to
the truth
diversity across all other levels
but courage and fidelity to the truth so
i do think that this is a time for
courage and again that's one of the
reasons that i was so attracted to your
work because of the pushback that it's
received pushbacks perhaps the most
diplomatic word i could say uh but
and you remain consistent and i see that
that's that's courage
and that's a model for us as
well so a couple of comments on that so
well optimally you want
the optimal pattern of action
to be part of your personality
and then you want
the story
of your life to be concordant with that
pattern of action and then you want the
propositions abstracted from that story
to be concordant with the story so then
you have the intellectual and let's call
it the literary and the behavioral
existing in harmony with one another and
i suppose a fully developed religious
system would
flesh out all three levels and you see
that in in catholicism you have the
patterns of action you have the stories
and you have the the the propositions
so i i agree with dr kaiser that
the dogma
is crucial and it's partly too because
the rational can undermine faith you
know and we always think as modern
people we think well if faith can be
undermined by rationality than it should
be but as a practicing clinician i see
how devastating that is so i had a
client for example who was an
extraordinarily creative person
brilliant person
and fundamentally a good person
but he had a very very critical rational
mind
and it was always
digging at his roots
and as long as he he was an architect
and an artist and
as long as he was engaged in creative
activity
he could live
but as soon as he started to think
his thinking killed him it was so
it was so brutal
everything was up for grabs everything
was questionable
you know and you should say well you
don't take anything on faith you know
it's like well try to live like that and
see what happens it that doesn't get at
the problem that the untrammeled
rational mind can be unbelievably
destructive in its
ability to go down to the depths and
undermine and and destroy
and so
the
the protective structure
that a functioning religious system
offers is some protection against
the
against that element of untrammeled
rationality
and that's also something i think the
the rationalist atheist types they just
maybe they haven't had enough experience
with
say seriously depressed people
who've been driven to the depths of
despair by
a mind that just won't stop uprooting
and
and destroying
you know that's not
only a personal thing in some sense
because
it's easy for you me anyone to become
possessed by these destructive ideas
and they're very powerful
and once they're part of us we need an
answer to them you know and we need an
answer to our her our nihilistic doubts
and
what
catholicism offers
i wouldn't say uniquely but but
definitely is
the consequence of thousands of years of
effort at
keeping that terribly destructive
destroyer of necessary faith at bay
and that's also a good way to
communicate it i think to young people
it's like look you're going to be
plagued by these existential
catastrophic existential doubts
what the hell's the point of it anyways
and that's particularly the case when
things aren't going well and you're
suffering and suffering unjustly it's
like what are you going to do then well
here's
here's how people have solved that
problem you know it's possible that
we're akin to deity in some sense that
there's something transcendentally
important about consciousness that you
play a crucial role in the structure of
existence
it's like no one
can say that for certain you know
because what the hell do we know but
it's the best we've been able to manage
in terms of
what was it milton
wasn't didn't milton write paradise laws
to justify the way of god
the ways of god to man
it's a hell of an ambition in some sense
that's what this entire religious
endeavor does the literary endeavor as
well
what's the point of all this what's the
meaning of this and
you know when you think about that in
two
two propositionally
and this i also saw this in my therapy
practice it's like well what's the
meaning of life and i could easily get
off on a nihilistic argument with some
of my more intelligent clients they had
a rejoinder for every proposition about
why life was valuable
but then if you said to them
don't be so sure that that part of you
is your friend look what it's doing to
you it's so destructive and it has all
of its self-justifying arguments and
they might even be coherent but look at
the consequences and then
contrast that
with
your own experience like when does that
sense of nihilistic despair disappear
you know for some people it's when
they're with people they love they're
with friends or family some people find
it in creative activity some people find
it in charity
there are various sources of meaning
and that's not propositional
you see it in your own life right you
can literally in therapy you have people
track that it's like well you're
nihilistically depressed let's let's
watch your life for a week and see how
that ebbs and flows with what you're
doing
and then see if we can get
you participating more in what makes it
ebb than what makes it flow and that's
empirical in a sense right i'm not
asking you to believe something i'm
asking you to watch the structure of
your own reality to see where meaning
manifests itself and then you could say
in some sense the sum total of
where meaning manifests itself that's
where god resides
and that relationship with god that you
described
as
as the
what would you say
as
that that has to be maintained by our
good behavior
i suppose that's that
desire
to live in that space of meaning
and
then you can propositionalize that you
can say well that's associated with love
and it's associated with courage it's
associated with these classical virtues
and it's not these things that we've
learned to deem as evil
and that's that's where you is that is
it reasonable to say that that's where
you find god if you're searching is that
the is that an appropriate way of
looking at it
i think so i i met a guy one time who
told me he went to a lecture
and the lecture was on god's existence
and the guy who was lecturing and then
after the lecture my friend came up to
him and said uh you know everything you
say is a bunch of malarkey there's no
god it's just your lecture is just
meaningless
and the guy said okay
what i want you to do is for the next
week i want you to treat everyone
that you meet
as if they were jesus in disguise
and the guy left the lecture and he went
home and you know he gets home and you
know mom's there doing the dishes and he
thought to himself well if this were
jesus and disguise doing the dishes i'd
probably go up and like help my mom do
the dishes and then dad came home from
work and rather than ignore him he said
hey dad how was how was work how's
everything going and you know because if
that were really jesus in disguise i
would do that and then they're eating
dinner together with the family and
there's one hamburger left
and he turns to his brother says hey why
don't you have this
and the guy told me his life was
completely transformed by literally one
week
of acting in this sort of way
and that's not really surprising pope
benedict talked about this in one of his
encyclicals that one way to god
is to act in this sort of way to act as
if god exists right right to act as if
other people are jesus in disguise and
you know mother teresa talked about that
too that in for her the poor and the
leper and the destitute
were all jesus
in disguise and so she served them as if
they were jesus and so that is one way
it seems to me to move towards god i
don't think it's the only way though and
the reason is that
i know a philosopher aleister mcintyre
who mentioned to us in class one day
that he was an atheist until he
carefully studied the arguments for
god's existence so there are at least
some people at least one person aleister
mcintyre who really did come to god
through that way but i think the more
common way is through
lived practice lived action yeah you you
brought up the the case of of severe
depression and um
you know
it is the case of course that
you can make
profoundly coherent arguments of for why
your life is meaningless and why
meaning there is just a vast nullity to
all existence but the question isn't are
they coherent the question is are they
true the question is are the premises
right because anything can be coherent
within false premises the question is is
it the case that your life is worth
nothing and the answer has to be no
that's a false statement it's a false
apprehension of reality oh look what
happens if you act that out
of course but even then you could say
well no i'd be doing a sum if within
within the grips of depression you'd
still be thinking that i am acting
according to a good given the premises
that i have about the meaninglessness of
my own life and of all life
so i think the foundation it keeps going
back to the same question the foundation
of truth must be there but then the next
thing to say is not that you are wrong
about your life being meaningless as a
false statement but that you're also
loved
you are loved
and it's i think that's the kind of
thing at least my own experience
that can take you out of the darkness
that your life is not about you and your
own thoughts it's not about you and the
systems that you are building
ultimately you are in response to
something much greater than you and that
thing that's greater than you is looking
at you and calling you out and saying i
love you so it's not it's not an either
or it's not well what's true
propositionally about the nature of
existence and is there a soul it is that
and
i'm calling you
which is a universal call for us as
catholics
this
exercise that you described dr kaiser
i believe that
when we see other people
except under
very extraordinary circumstances we see
an illusion that we project upon them
mostly it's a simplifying illusion we
don't see the whole person partly i
suppose because we we couldn't tolerate
the
the complete vision
it would be too much for us you know so
our doors of perception are three
quarters closed and exactly why that is
isn't obvious but
i do believe that the more accurately
you perceive a person
the more you perceive them in the manner
that you described
you see this eternal
recurring
conscious
hero
striving against the darkness
it's
and when you treat people like that
of course they're
what compelled by that
it's a compelling way to be interacted
with
although i don't know what it is is that
maybe
it's not obvious how much of that you
can tolerate which is a very strange
thing too
you know
i'm thinking about this
most of what we perceive is our memory
and sometimes that
is stripped away and we see what's there
but seeing what's there is awes aw
inspiring
it's it's it's gripping and and it
instills terror and i think that's the
same as the burning bush
and in some sense everything is a
burning bush
but
you're blinded to it
the
you you see what's there
i think when you really love someone a
child
you really see that in a child if you if
you're a parent
right
you see
you don't see a generic baby you see
that actual person
so that memory that
pushes generic baby into your field of
vision dissipates and you see what's
actually there and that love drives that
i imagine it does that
it love seems to
like i always saw when people fall in
love with one another they see the
perfection that could conceivably exist
it's like the curtains of
of illusion
pull apart momentarily and you see the
paradisal state that could be there
hypothetically if everything was done
properly
and that drives the love
and then maybe if you work across time
you can achieve that to some degree
you know because other people think
about themselves as deluded when they're
in love and
that's a very cynical way of looking at
it
it certainly doesn't apply
to the love between a parent and a child
yeah i think i think you're right i mean
i know in my own life
having children has been such a
unbelievably enriching
experience and i think about
you know especially when kids are little
and they're asleep you go in there and
they're just sleeping and you see their
little chest moving up and down
there's something painfully beautiful
about that i mean you just wish it could
go on
just indefinitely
and
for me that is something that taught me
something about about god's love right
if god really is
god the father
well then you know we that's sort of how
he looks at us and he sees the good
he sees the effort and
of course there's imperfections too but
i don't know it for me
having children is a kind of
i try to sometimes tell my students
most of whom don't have kids what it's
like and it's very hard to describe so
the best way i came up with was well
remember when you were a little child
you're like six
and you thought um
oh boys have cooties girls have cooties
and the idea of romance or kissing
someone is just repulsive and then you
know you could imagine trying to explain
to a six-year-old look at some point
you're gonna look at someone else and
just find this person unbelievably
captivating and you're going to want to
kiss them and you can say the words but
a little kid's been like
no way that that's hard to describe and
and i think becoming a parent is similar
to that in that
yeah it seems to me
that it is so enriching
that uh and has given so much at least
to my life and including calling out
something for me that would have never
been elicited because there's kind of
sacrifices that you'll do for a kid that
you'll never do for you know an adult
so that that's interesting
that ties in with this this idea that
you brought forward of treating
everybody as if they were manifestation
of christ
you see that
meaningful fragility in your children
and it's beautiful
and
maybe if you're
if you've been warped and hurt you get
resentful about it
and jealous of it and that can lead to
all sorts of terrible things but to the
degree that you can that you're
privileged to see that
that calls you to be a better person
and you can think of that you know
biologically well
you have these fragile creatures
that you're responsible for
of course that's going to call you to a
higher mode of
action because otherwise they're not
going to live you know so it's it's very
practical but
so then but what you see there is if
that if you
view someone with love
then it's incumbent upon you to treat
them as if they're valuable
and then the more you treat other people
as if they're valuable
the better person you are that just
comes along for the ride in some sense
so none of that seems questionable to me
that that seems solid
and so then maybe the more love you view
other people with
the higher the moral demand that's
placed on you and then i would say too
well then
that's another reason why
it's so important to be truthful and and
in some sense to be good because it
isn't obvious to me that you can
withstand that moral load
if you're
compromised by
too much sin
it's too much
and then that's another thing that that
we're not very good at teaching young
people about you know we shouldn't do
that
you know it's like
there's a
sanctimonious authority that goes along
with that that's the wrong tone it's
more like
you know
i don't know how you lay it out properly
but you tell people that you love how to
avoid the road to hell
and you don't do that because you're
shaking your finger at them or because
you're
a moral authority
you do it because you don't want them to
burn
and
i think there's too much of the moral
authority still in the church and not
enough of the
you know the love that
helps people avoid
the fire
i assume
i think that you've just beautifully
described is the the unity of the love
commandment that you you love your you
love god with all your heart and all
your soul and all your mind and you love
your neighbor as yourself
the love the love of god identifies the
pattern and then they interplay between
the love of the neighbor and the love of
the self they're they're inextricable
they're differentiated but inextricably
intertwined
and so to to love the neighbor is to see
the neighbor as he or she actually is
and to respond to the actuality not to
your desires not to what you want this
person to be in a utilitarian or
instrumental sense but to the reality of
that eternal soul right there
and through that then you see who you
are
that's a commentary on the ten
commandments right that's christ's
summation of the ten commandments so
that's another
another
illustration of that abstraction
proper behavior the story on top of that
the propositions that would be the ten
commandments let's say so then christ is
challenged on the ten commandments
something like
rank order these if you're so wise
right exactly because you're going to
say something heretical
and christ does this unbelievable
sleight of mind
and and extracts out two superordinate
principles
and it's done in such a compelling way
that the interlocutor who's basically a
prosecutorial mind
like an inquisitionist in some sense
is reduced to silence
that's that's a very powerful story it's
one of those stories you read that you
think
it's not obvious how someone could have
made that up
there's a lot of genius
there's an immense
well of moral genius in that story and
the idea that that's some sort of casual
false construct
you know produced
for the purposes of power it's like well
you try to write a story that short that
that's that is that wise see how far you
get with it
so
yeah those those stories are all over
the gospels i mean think about the story
where
the woman is caught in adultery
and they say to jesus well you know the
law says we should stone her to death
you know what do you say
and they're trying to trap him of course
because if he says well don't stone her
to death then they say well you're
against moses huh you're a religious
heretic and then if he says go ahead and
throw the stones then he's going against
his message of mercy but jesus of course
says very famously
let whoever has the first sin
cast the first or whoever has no sin
casts the first stone
and you know everyone has to drop their
stones and go away yeah and then he says
to her of course go
and sin no more
so that that kind of story you think
yeah you'd have to have quite an
imagination
be a kind of literary genius to come up
with this and i think it's important in
part because
christ combines both
right that is to say we have the command
and the commandment say not to commit
adultery is there for a reason i'm sure
you know from your clinical practice
that you know that can cause
unbelievable problems you know for
couples and families
uh but he also has the mercy so jesus
combines the the high commands of
justice and with this high mercy and in
a way that's what the church is seeking
to do now always imperfectly because
we're imperfect but but both need to be
there there needs to be
the uh moral uh the high moral calling
but also the
great mercy both because i think one
without the other is going to be
unbalanced
and and the high moral calling again
is for our own good the the law is a
form of grace this this is how we
flourish this is how
we become happy
now of course we fail which brings in
the mercy component but that's another
terrible misconstrue of religion broadly
and specifically christianity and
catholicism is that somehow these rules
were were premised on on
control or power as their motivating
reason for coming into existence it's
the exact opposite
it's to liberate it's to liberate us
from ourselves
i guess it's the other thing that that
seems to have worked in my lectures is
like a lot of this
a lot of the work i've done was
motivated by my attempts i suppose to
understand hell
and then more than that like
how is it that you become an active
contributor to hell
and you might say well hell isn't real
well and i would say that well you
haven't looked enough
if you think that's true
you're fortunate enough so that you can
believe that's not true
it's like you know nothing about history
and
you've been unbelievably sheltered in
your own life if you don't believe that
hell is real
and you know
maybe
only someone cruel would wish that that
ignorance be stripped away from you
but if you study history as a
perpetrator
well then
if you study history
you believe in hell and if you study
history as a perpetrator then you see
how your own inequity contributes to
that
and then it's not unreasonable to say
well if you love people you would try to
guide them away from that and
when i did my maps of meaning lectures
at the university and in public that's
always in the back of my mind it's
well look at what happened in germany
and look at what happened in the soviet
union and look what happened in china
and
how do you act so that that happens well
i i wouldn't make that happen it's like
if you say that then you
would because you don't know enough
you'd because if you do you'd say yes i
could contribute to that and i probably
am and i should be terrified enough to
stop if i only knew how and then
these guidelines to love and to tell the
truth they are in fact
protection against exactly that kind of
catastrophe
yeah and i think it's true not only in
those uh very dramatic examples of hell
like the gulag but i think it's true in
a really everyday sense i mean yes
hell can start here on earth um in a
very everyday sort of way so i think if
somebody
actually that i know on my block and
this person is incredibly
angry at everyone even people that try
to help this person she's always angry
at them and she's filled with hatred and
bitterness and everything's bad and
and so for this person i would say
she is already
living in hell the beginning of hell at
least here on earth i mean her life as
far as i can tell is just really really
hellish in every respect and then people
in contact with her she makes their life
polish very often and the reverse is
true too there can be people here and
now who are already living in the
beginnings of heaven they're filled with
love for god they're filled with love
for other people they love themselves
they
they're living this heavenly life
because at the end of the day at least
on on the catholic view
what is heaven well what heaven is is
perfect
love of god perfect love of other people
perfect love of yourself
and what is hell what's the opposite
it's a lack of all that right it's
lacking love of god lacking love for
other people lacking love for yourself
it's being filled with hatred so heaven
and hell i would say really begin right
now
and
in the life to come i they say they're
intensified they're deepened so and this
is the vision of dante right that that
you know heaven or hell is something
that
all of its punishments are meant to show
that the sin
is its own punishment in some respect
right all the punishments that say that
people in hell experience are all a
natural outgrowth of their own
bad behavior here below and we can see
this in everyday life with for instance
people that
um you know end up destroying their
relationships destroying their families
and they end up isolated alone and again
living this sort of hellish existence
but unfortunately in those cases they
are as it were their own worst enemy
yeah i think that connects back to the
your insights into morality as well and
that
it is remarkable
just in a cultural sense that that your
work which has rules in the title 12 of
them right two books
has garnered the audience there's
obviously a that it has there's
obviously a profound hunger cross
culturally
cross
linguistically
for what you are saying and what you are
saying is about the necessity of
rules i think what we have here is we
now have a couple generations that have
been liberated from rules
and
we get to see what that actually looks
like in practice
and it's it's not just the the the
possibility of these external forms of
hell it absolutely is that but the
internal forms of hell as well
depression and anxiety i can't think of
any greater hell
than being in the grips of of of severe
depression and severe anxiety and the
worst thing that you can tell somebody
in that position is do whatever you want
and invent anything according to your
own fancy
it's poison
so the the fact that there there are
rules and that these rules correspond
with reality and they're for our good
and for our happiness
i think just speaks again to not only
the necessity of the rules but
the fact that we are all called to
something greater and when we stop that
call
hell
begins to take over soul by soul
you have their directions
if you're lost and you're trying to get
somewhere and someone provides you with
directions you have to turn right at a
certain point and left at a certain
point and you don't say well
to hell with these rules
you think thank god for these rules
because you know i'll wander off the
path and then where will i end up at the
least lost
and so yeah it's
all right so i want to close with one
more question if that's okay unless you
guys have something else you want to
talk about
um
what are you doing right at fire what's
working
at word on fire yeah
what's working
what's working i think the um
on a lot of it i would say it sort of
follows the contours of of the
conversation that we've had
uh the the rules are there the dogmatic
clarity is there the arguments are there
the
the propositions and the defense of
those propositions is all there so
there's sort of a we call apologetic
foundation to it so it's necessary but
again not the most important one of word
on fire's
uh
ways of describing the work that it does
is is acting at the intersection of
faith and culture and leading with
beauty
so
again there's theological freezing this
if god exists
then god is the unity of all that is
good all that is true and all that is
beautiful and these aren't mutually
exclusive you don't and you don't have
to choose one or the other
so the
the mission of this apostolate is to
without any kind of denigration of the
importance of truth is to lead with
beauty
and and with that to to reopen the eyes
of the culture to the possibility of
being happy
and and living a life that is
genuinely enchanted
in a non-magical real sense
is it working are you seeing results
i think so i think so so
you know
i follow a word on fire very closely in
terms of their the the materials they
produce and i benefit from them and
enjoys them a lot and i think part of
the success is the
um
distinctive work of bishop robert baron
i mean i think that he is to be credited
uh his own way his own intellectual way
of putting things and his winning
way of persuading others i think is is
very
very powerful and has seen uh seen great
results so so i'm very grateful to be
connected with word on fire and as i say
not only do i sometimes
produce content for them but also i
benefit personally from listening to
his uh podcasts um his sermons etc so
it's been a real benefit for me
i'm going to be talking to him in a
couple of days along with jonathan pagio
and john verveiki so i'm very much
looking forward to that
an extension of this conversation i
suppose so it is there anything that we
didn't talk about that you think is
vital
that we should talk about
well one thing i wanted to ask you and
and encourage you really would be if at
some point you could
carry out the plan that you've talked
about before of giving lectures on
exodus and i realize given covet
restrictions and things like that maybe
it's it's impossible right now to rent
out a huge place etc but i wonder if you
could even just do it via
video right that you
you know or even to a very small group
i i think that your lectures on genesis
were such a huge benefit for literally
millions of people
and i think that
lecturing on exodus which in some ways
is an even more gripping story i mean
it's it's very dramatic
i think that could be an enormous
benefit to many many people so anyway i
just want to was wondering if you were
planning on doing that or if you'd be
willing maybe given covet and
restrictions maybe to do it in a
different format slightly different than
you did before
i'm trying to figure out how to do it
i've
had a lot of health trouble and it's
got in the way in a big way i'm trying
to figure out how to do it and to figure
out if i can do it it's not obvious to
me what i'm capable of doing and what i
can't do so but
it's definitely something i would love
to do i'm i mean i have the ideas
i work i developed them in the lectures
obviously but
i would love to do it
so
god willing and all that
i i would just end with uh really a
statement i suppose is i
and i'm sure you already know this but
there are many many believers like
ourselves who who are who are praying
for you
and who are so grateful for the work
that you are doing whatever your
personal beliefs are and however you
work that out
we're so grateful for
your voice
uh on the international stage and the
kinds of
of arguments that you're making and the
kinds of appeals to
to becoming better both individually and
socially as communities
uh you you are a light in the darkness
for for many people and again i i'm
saying that as a believer from within
the christian community looking out at
someone who's not claiming to be a
christian
but i just want you to know that we are
praying for you and that we we wish you
all the best
it's very much appreciated very much
appreciated
so i hope that i can
i really hope that i can do these exodus
lectures that would be something so
i'm working out a way to do it i
i have a group of people maybe that i'm
going to talk to exodus about i might
just record those
discussions like this we'll walk through
it with some people who can help comment
so i think i might be able to manage
that
we'll see well thank you very much
gentlemen um
and for the attention that you showed me
in the book and all of that and for the
work you're doing with word on fire and
hopefully we'll get a chance to talk
again we'll see what people think of
this conversation see what they might
want to hear more about
or less about
so
thank you jordan thank you thank you all
right bye bye